how you guys doing
good man how are you good to see you
nice to see you uh i'll start with uh
keanu thank you for the constantine
panel
it went great i just wanted to say
thanks thank you
i want to start with how much i enjoyed
this movie uh it absolutely feels like a
bill and ted sequel
uh i just had so much fun with it and i
just wanted to say congrats
and thank you so much for making it i'm
so happy to hear you say that
i mean we're only just starting to get
reactions from people especially people
who
you know we trust or are hoping they
like it so that's great to hear
yeah no i i had an absolute blast um one
of the things about this is that it
feels i feel like i've been
hearing about a bill and ted sequel for
like 10 years um
was this the first time in since the
making of the second film that you guys
like had
the ability the money if you will to
make the sequel um like what was it that
sort of finally got it made fans
of all the writers the writers had an
idea that they came to alex and i with
about
i mean i don't know what is it alex like
eight nine
years ago yeah yeah as well yeah
and you know the thing is is that and
it's been this way with every villain's
head movie the bill and said movies are
hard to get made
they're hard to make and there's always
some whack-a-doodle thing that happens
when they get released
and that has literally happened with all
three of them and somehow they persevere
i don't know what that means but that's
what's happened so
the short answer to your question is yes
it got made now because that's when
everything came together and mostly
the financing with the right script with
everything else
and it took that long it did take a long
time yeah i think a lot of people don't
realize the first movie
wasn't it maybe just gonna go straight
to dvd not even
it was on a shelf it was not even gonna
get released at all
uh dvd and it was
easy yeah
it was made for a wing of dilaurentis uh
uh dg and they went under and the film
was gone and we were told it was never
going to come out and
a full year later it was picked up by a
small company called nelson and tested
and it tested incredibly well and then
and then it came out but it was it was
done like we were told it was never
coming out it's so crazy uh one of the
things that i find
so amazing about bill and ted is the
merchandise
because when you think about this movie
it's not like some superhero movie it's
not
you don't see bill and ted as
merchandise a cartoon
cereal toys it's just it's just crazy
for you guys what's like the most what's
your favorite merchandise that's come
out of this
and do you still own any of it
i don't have any merchandise i mean i
think alex when the
cereal wasn't the cereal made by purina
or so
yeah it was it was made by a dog food
company yeah
yeah feeling their dog food tasted
better but i i don't remember completely
yeah
did you guys actually ever try the
cereal i did not
oh did you yeah okay
what was it did it taste like dog food
or would you eat it again
i recall maybe it was like in the kind
of world of alphabets do you remember
that cereal
yeah it's just super sweet right an oat
based sugar carrying
disability yeah i think it was very good
for dogs
specifically for some reason
what i'm curious uh obviously you guys
haven't played bill and ted in a long
time
what was the first stuff that you filmed
for face the music
and how nervous were you on that first
day like playing the older version of
these
iconic characters yeah our first day
actually was a really good way to start
uh the director dean pariso who we love
and i think made a really
fabulous film um had us started uh
getting into a booth
or actually in the booth and then
getting out of the booth um
yeah no getting in the booth and that
was it was kind of cool to get into the
phone booth
which is our time traveling machine yeah
it was trippy
uh i mean we had done a lot of
rehearsing and keanu and i have been
working together a lot
already and uh you know we worked on
developing the script for years so
it wasn't um you know literally going
zero to sixty
but there is a moment when you're making
a film where all of the
stuff and the rehearsal and the mishigas
and whatever
has to get cast aside you just have to
actually do it and uh
it was so it was fun to be in the booth
it was and it was weird it was weirdly
nostalgic in a way i didn't quite expect
i think
keanu and i kind of looked at the booth
sitting there in like a parking lot
and looked at each other like oh we're
getting back in the booth you know
it was very symbolic it was like batman
putting on the cape but
not um and there was a little circus a
time
book just like when i was 21 years old
and
there was i mean it was all very strange
and lovely i mean it was sweet
but strange i loved the makeup that bill
corso did
for you guys um right here he's saying
thank you by the way but yeah for real
yeah oh that's great i thought that the
makeup that you guys that he did was
fantastic i
love the i don't want to get into
spoilers but the older versions of you
guys
it's it's really good you know um
especially the prison thing
um can you guys sort of talk about those
future we have to have
we have to credit kevin yeager who was a
very big part of that as well so
uh kevin designed the the actual
prosthetic stuff and
bill worked on the makeup as well but
credit where it's due because kevin did
the old later bogus journey and a bunch
of that stuff as well
well could you guys both talk about
working like sort of
doing those future versions and uh and
working with kevin
and you know bill yeah it was uh
it was actually one of the things that i
was really looking forward to
and i thought was really clever in the
film um
and it was you know we've we got to play
different versions of bill and ted and
bogus journey and
um it was cool to kind of carry on that
motif but also just to play these
different versions of
of bill and ted not only just how
they're incarnated but also their
attitudes like how they were
behaviorally dealing with
each other um was a a
hoot and the makeups and stuff were
great and
and it was you know it's fun you're
really you're like you know
you're playing it's pretend it's like
you know you're putting on costumes
it's fun i had stopped acting for a long
time and i
and the last thing i did was freaked um
with bill corso and with keanu and
actually there were other people
on that side who had worked on that as
well so
it was really a treat to come back and
and be able to work with everybody again
but also i love acting
in prosthetic makeup it's a weird thing
i think my kids think i'm nuts but
uh so i was really grateful and you know
to be working with keanu we love
acting together and to sort of be in
that playground and
not only playing bill and ted off of
each other but playing these crazy
versions of bill and ted off of each
other was
it was really really fun i think the
thing that people
love about bill and ted is the their
friendship
that they're just best friends and
things just don't come between them
um can you sort it do you think that's
what it is that really resonates
and has resonated for so many years with
the fans
i would imagine that's part of it um
yeah i mean it's cool that you know
i mean growing up it was like butch and
sundance right it was newman and redford
like you know like you thought they must
be friends and like they're doing their
thing and when you saw them together
they were so cool you know
it was like i don't know yeah so i i'm
i'm speaking like an audience member
and like enjoying that kind of aspect to
performances and characters and
and i i hopefully you know that's one of
the reasons why people
enjoy building tech it's very
challenging
rolling a film out this summer obviously
and has been for a lot of films and
and it's been a very challenging time
for people and we've all been very
worried about
you know the economic state for
exhibitors for instance and
not wanting them to go under and
supporting them while keeping people
safe
so you know we we really just want to
make sure the movie was good
and then got out in a way that people
felt comfortable with you know
right you do not have to worry about the
movie being good i have to rap
i'm just going to say again congrats on
the sequel i had so much fun watching it
i hope it's a huge hit thank you so much
have a great day ciao